it's called the OOD but he calls it his
baby tobot azaa we even returned to his
besieged hometown just to get it before
fleeing as a refugee there was a fight
between the regime and the al-qaeda so
they changed the route somehow it was
route in the desert so I went back I was
able to get into the city then I got out
my baby I waited about 10 days more then
I got out my instrument and I fled to
lebanon again then from Lebanon to Yemen
tabeta zoe has been living in germany
for a year now he plays in a group
called Banda internet sonali together
with dresden musicians and other asylum
seekers for a rhythm different than the
anti-foreigner slogans chanted at some
rallies in the city
tobot doesn't like the anti-migrant
demonstrations in dresden but he does
like the counter movement they have
spawned in support of the refugees
they're trying to counteract this effect
with much involvement much engagement
and yeah I got I got much more for much
more help than my friends in other city
in mission for example learning German
has also helped him find friends in
Dresden tobot has language classes five
times a week he thinks it's important
and not only because he wants to
continue studying medicine that's musica
they've all musicians in Dresden speak
English like they do in Berlin so I
always have to speak in German it makes
it easier to learn I'm faja
tobot always has his ode on hand he
practices two hours a day at home in the
park wherever he's a talented performer
and when rock star sting was recently on
the lookout for an ood player on his new
record a friend of his gut tobot the gig
we had fun we played along a couple of
times then we recorded each one recorded
alone and actually it went very much
faster that I suspected I thought it
would take the full day or something but
actually took a couple of hours tobot
says getting to meet sting was an
inspiration but when he thinks about his
hometown the feeling is sadness Dara
Azure is in eastern Syria and now lies
in ruins tobot used to go over this
bridge to school each day this is how it
looked before the war really knowing
that this bridge would not be there with
all its related memories it's all it's
it's it's really painful really he
escaped from Syria and made his way
through several Arab countries when the
26 year old finally arrived to stay with
good friends in Yemen suddenly war broke
out there too I still get nightmares
some time for all the solos that I have
I have experienced it was I think it
could be the worst the worst time of my
life there in the war in Yemen
music brings him some inner peace but
Todd that doesn't believe syria's
conflict will end any time soon tobot
azami sees his future in germany
you